all right this is my favorite [ __ ]
dude this might be my favorite character
from the movie of my life going back the
oddball
so i worked um from seventh grade until
into college i worked at my friend's
dad's junkyard all right when we were
young we just got recycling put together
and put it in this dumpster and send it
off you know all these old cars recycled
and [ __ ] and as we got older i started
junkyards are like country clubs for
poor white people yeah like that is like
mike young's dad yeah worked at junk
yards
i learned more and those junkyards i
learned what cocaine was and what it did
to you you know all working around these
are guys that legit dropped out in
seventh grade i learned that in new
orleans that yeah yeah
so
this guy we had this we had
we had this little business and i didn't
know it at the time i'm driving stolen
cars i couldn't figure out why my
friend's dad would take me to these
parking lots when i turned 16. he'd be
like we're just going up to the walmart
real quick you're going to drive this
car back i didn't give all i wanted to
do was drive and i would get in all
these cars and the [ __ ] keys would be
in there and then sooner or later i was
like it's the thing though
and then after about a half a dozen of
those i'm like oh and i realized
i'm driving a stolen car we take it we
make it disappear
it gets reported to insurance they cash
out got it yeah
so i didn't know i was in on that but
i'm in on that so
we had this specialist all right this
guy's name was meso and now this junk
yard was in frederick county maryland in
baltimore city to frederick county it
could take an hour and a half one way my
job is to pick meso up down in the and
it's a it's i'll tell you what kind of
neighborhood is there's an area called
madame mall i walked in the diamond mall
i walked two feet in the first thing i
heard was white boy and i was like let
me get the [ __ ]
out don't need to kill i would have
killed time not myself
so
this guy's specialty was rolling back
odometers okay and he could do anything
he could remember the early digital
odometer that looked like the green
alarm clocks remember those yeah it
would be like 86 you know and he could
roll them all back
and i know some people are like why does
that matter well
we would bring this guy out and he'd
roll back the odometers on all these
engines so let's say we owned a car with
200 000 he rolls it back to 85. we're
over doubling our money on that engine
right
so my job is to go down to the city pick
meso up bring him out to the yard and
he's going to spend the day rolling back
odometers and then i got to take him
down now i pick him up and i've never
seen him uh they just tell me you're
going to get this guy at this address
i'm like all right and this tall black
man comes out he's slender he's got a
kango on and he doesn't have a toolbox
or anything he's got one of those
old-school leather doctor alligator bags
you know what i'm talking about that's
his phone yeah yeah yeah that's his
toolbox
and i'm like this dude's [ __ ] done
and he gets in and we just small talk
for an hour and a half out there because
the truth is i'm probably
21 i don't have the balls to ask him how
do you do this illegal [ __ ] or whatever
and i take him out i go about my day he
goes about his and then i got to take
him back and now
i've got the balls
and i go uh this is a true story i go
hey man how do you learn how to do all
that and you know he's telling me and
just a natural course of conversation i
go man that is something and he goes
that ain't [ __ ] and i was like here we
[ __ ] go i'm about to get a goddamn
nugget of some old black man wisdom and
he goes you want to know what something
is and i go i definitely want to know
what something is and he goes all right
next time your dick's hard and i was
like yeah i was like wait
like i say he's like you want to hear
about this but yes i definitely want to
use all right next time your dick's hard
put it in your left hand
and then you put your right one over it
and if there's anything still sticking
out at the top that's something
that's what he [ __ ] told me
that's the name of my next album special
whatever that's something that's what
i'm calling it based on that meso bro i
couldn't get over that